olivier marleix qs députés l est
républicain d'eure-et-loir
bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous
pour commenter à cette nomination jean
castex qui remplace edouard philippe
votre réaction et est attendu au je sais
pas mais en tout cas ce que je t'ai
j'observe c'est que c'est le choix de la
continuité parce que c'est le choix d'un
technocrate pour remplacer un premier
ministre qui était quand même déjà très
très fortement très fortement techno et
je partage l'analyse de 2,2 de votre
politique péter logghe est intervenue
juste avant
edouard philippe à la limite il est un
peu plus d'épaisseur politique parce
qu'il incarnait à ceux de courant québec
était juppéiste il avait il y avait
quelques réseaux d'un pays là le nouveau
prémices n'est vraiment qu'un cas c'est
pas parce que il a travaillé pendant
deux ou trois ans comme directeur de
cabinet de xavier bertrand entend que
encore que quelques fonctionnaires ou
qu'il a occupé une fonction à l'elysée
pendant deux ans sur nicolas sarkozy n'a
encore sur des dossiers techniques qui
les autres choses fondamentalement que
qu'avec un technocrate et il n'a pas de
réseau il n'a pas de vrais réseaux
politiques et donc la conséquence pour
le président de la république c'est que
finalement on voit un président
aujourd'hui qui a une majorité à
l'assemblée nationale qui est quand même
pas très pas très consistantes on veut
dire qu'il n'y ait pas un relais très
puissant pour lui il a il a un ancrage
dans le pays qui est très faible on l'a
vu aux élections municipales avec des
scores absolument incroyable appliquant
marche qui fait 1,6 pour cent à
marseille par exemple cent ont dit que
même assez long sur l'absence d'ancrage
et finalement il y avait avec edouard
philippe il avait réussi avec le temps à
avoir un petit 1.2 ministre qui
titulaire d un peu politiquement qui
était le seul qui avait une petite
existence autonome et sans doute par
orgueil unis n'a pas supporté n'a pas
supporté simple et donc il leur a
approuvé mise demain qui lui même
finalement on va le laisser seul
plus que jamais face au pays je pense
que disponibles
c'est un situation actuelle est un peu
compliquée pour pour le président
macrophages a encore un peu plus
compliqué lr à matignon télé remontait
la stratégie d' emmanuel macron est-ce
que c'est d'affirmer cette cette
politique de droite il faut plus dire à
allaire il a il a été adhérent de
république à elle été élue locale des
ricard il a démissionné
je crois savoir il ya quinze jours donc
il dépêché nous voilà jeu c'est pour
nous la page l'anah page est tournée
que veut faire maintenant avec celle ci
évidemment le snack aux deux côtés
toujours débauchage ces patrons qui
c'est de prendre deux grands piliers à
droite à gauche pour pour troubler les
lignes politiques nous faut encore je
pense pas que jean castex entraînera
grand chose derrière lui en réalité à la
différence de jean philippe qui est
qu'il y avait une fois encore ce réseau
ce réseau juppéiste mais le vrai sujet
au delà de ça c'est effectivement un
remaniement pour pour quelle politique
j'ai regardé les sondages qui disent
actuellement les français ne demandait
pas tant à charge en prémice qu'un
changement de politique
1 75% ce chiffre est décalé ben il est
quand même très très fort 75% des
français veulent une autre politique
or là dessus c'est c'est plus flou que
jamais me présentant un public a fait
que même de deux formidables grand écart
ces derniers temps il pendant les crises
du que weeds a dit qu'il allait se
réinventer complètement sans mettre en
cause lui même
je vous rappelle qu'on était déjà sans
cesse dans un nouveau monde donc je suis
a encore du nouveau sur le nouveau et
puis et puis l'a finalement
je lis ce matin dans les journaux qui
peut pas changer de cap donc enfin c'est
du grand n'importe quoi je pense que
tant la république est en grande partie
à ces paumés je pense pas qu'il y avait
forcément les idées extrêmement clair
lorsqu'il a été élu je suis de
reparcourir sonçon son livre révolution
pour son compte y avait pas un programme
très puissant la crise économique a fait
voler en éclats et l'actrice du que
vides a fait voler en éclat un certain
nombre de ses repères notamment dans
cette cette mondialisation sans sens
sans frein et qui est très destructrice
pour l'économie française dont il est un
peu obligé de faire semblant de revenir
là dessus mais en réalité je pense qu'il
est incapable d'inventer un nouveau cap
pour les français c'est pour ça que du
coup il change pas de cap
jean castex ne fait plus partie des
républicains néanmoins il a travaillé
avec xavier bertrand nicolas sarkozy il
vient de la droite mais c'est un
gaulliste social d'après certaines
sources ce que vous pensez qu'il a les
épaules et le profil pour pour maintenir
fermement
j'ai adhéré au mouvement gaulliste que
j'avais 15 ans je suis jamais croisé
jean castex à une réunion de 10
militants
sauf depuis qu'il est engagé qui est
arrivé en cabinet ministériel
d'abord c'est d'abord un fonctionnaire
derrière ça c'est amusant ce que j'ai vu
que le président n'a recueilli que lui
imposait comme directeur de cabinet à
matignon l'ancien secrétaire général
adjoint de l'elysée sous qui devait
succéder à lui-même sous françois
hollande donc en fait on le pays va être
gouvernée par de monsieur macro ça se
fait en général adjoint de l'elysée soit
hollande comme premier ministre l'ancien
ancien secrétaire général adjoint de
l'elysée sur sarkozy il vient d'ailleurs
des cabines à un autre spectacle à
l'unité nationale ovine actional façon
france façon macro ans c'est l'union des
techno de tous bords que c'est pour moi
c'est de très mauvaises augures en
termes de en termes de réformes
politiques et le tour du pays aurait
besoin
parlons un petit peu peut-être d'edouard
philippe qui est montée dans les
sondages pendant l'épidémie haïti
maintenant quitte
matignon est ce que vous pensez qu'il ya
là un futur candidat pour 2022
non je vois pas jouer absolument pas
quel espace politique il aurait edouard
philippe latry a trahi sa famille
politique
si tenté qu'il était vraiment un homme
de droite d'ailleurs enfin ce qu'est une
attrait lima il m'a trahi pour rejoindre
l' aventure macro nist donc il fait
partie des sept espèces de l'alliance
des centres
autour d'eux autour d' emmanuel macron
s'il veut être candidat il sera candidat
de la halle dans la danse créneau
politique donc il serait il sera un
grand problème pour pourrait mener macro
ne sera pas un problème pour pour la
droite
donc je pense jeu correct et c'est pas
vraiment ce pas vraiment un sujet c'est
ça va être un fantasme pour quelques-uns
peut-être un peu comme michel rocard mme
qui était d'ailleurs le premier mentor
dedans philippe a été longtemps à
fantasmes pour le pour le centre gauche
bon politiquement ça s'est jamais
traduit par rien du tout donc dans
philippe harache pense à peu près le
même destin c'est le fantasme de rocard
du centre droit christian jacob a réagi
à cette nomination il a dit en matière
de trahison on a déjà donné est ce que
vous êtes du même avis on a déjà donné
oui bon on a déjà souffert parce que
c'est sait jamais si jamais agréable une
politique de voir le voir ce genre de
chose se produire après après ça révèle
aussi selon moi ne m'en sers dench
abesque évident survie politique c'est à
dire que quand on est au pouvoir pendant
longtemps peut-être qu'on attire un
certain nombre de personnes notamment de
très hauts fonctionnaires parce que le
point commun de ces gens qui nous
trahissent souvent que sont des sondés
et des hauts fonctionnaires venus à la
politique à cette can ghorfi liste car
bruno le maire sait qu'aujourd'hui du
nouveau premier ministre
finalement ce cheval sur paille soit à
la part conditions sont là pour
opportunités d'exercer le pouvoir et et
en même temps ils nous ont amenés
parfois
a peut-être trop modéré ce qui fait
votre engagement politique
moi je me souviens je commence à avoir
un peu de bouteille je me souviens de
l'arrivée d'alain juppé comme secrétaire
général du rpr sous chirac et c'est vrai
qu'on a une rupture avec l'arrivée
d'alain juppé juppé est un techno il
succédait à des gens comme charles
pasqua qui étaient des gens de
conviction
là un vrai gaulliste social engagé dans
la résistance
rien à voir donc on parle aujourd'hui et
jupe et finalement nous avait amené
peut-être à nous autres cuillères plus
trop à nous éloigner un certain nombre
de nos idées de moi je fais partie de
ceux qui considèrent que tous ceux qui
s'en vont finalement ils font
paradoxalement ils font du bien de sa
vie politique parce que ils vont nous
aider
bayrou peu plus clair sur sur ce que
sont nos vrais conditions ce sera le mot
de la fin merci infiniment olivier
marleix qui se rappelle que vous êtes
député les républicains à d'eure-et-loir